[Musik]
warten auf die nächsten Zug aus Kiew auf
neue Schicksale Menschen auf der Flucht
denen Jever helfen will sie ist 15
selbst aus der Ostukraine geflohen mit
Mutter kleinen Bruder Tante das war im
März sie hat polnisch gelernt übersetzt
am Grenzbahnhof im polnischen chemische
ich kam am 6 märz in Polen an und am 21
hatte ich einen Termin beim Zahnarzt
also dachte ich ich bleibe zwei Wochen
in Polen und dann gehe ich zurück
Jever ist geblieben aber viele wollen
von hier aus zurück in die Ukraine je
nach Kriegslage
wir haben nicht viel Zeit
der Zug nach Krakau geht gleich raus sie
wollen weiter innerhalb Polens schon
seit der Krim Annexion 2014 lebten mehr
als eine Million Ukraine in Polen
Anlaufstelle für die neuen deshalb
bleiben nirgendwo so viele geflohene wie
in Polen hier war wohnt jetzt in
chemische in einer Wohnung von
Verwandten
jeder hat Stress wenn ein neues Leben
beginnt
als ich ankam verstand ich keine
polnischen Wörter jetzt schon aber nicht
immer
wenn meine Klassenkameraden was auf
polnisch sagten habe ich nur
gehört und nichts verstanden
90 Kilometer von der Grenze entfernt wer
Ukraine aufnahm bekam vier Monate lang
vom Staat 8 Euro pro Kopf und Tag das
ist vorbei manch ein aufgenommener
Muster raus irina hat die Wohnung
gemietet liebt von den Ersparnissen sie
kam im Juni mit der vierjährigen Daria
aus der Hölle von herson
ich wasche mir morgens das Gesicht
und bringe mich in die richtige Laune
Bruder
ich muss für meine Tochter weiterleben
ich muss lächeln
das ist alles was ich im Moment machen
kann so wie ich es begreife
jeden Morgen der Anruf bei ihrer Mutter
die in Kiew geblieben ist
wie es geht naja nicht so gut wir haben
wieder Sirenen gehabt seit 5 Uhr morgens
ja deswegen sitzen wir hier und beten
Mutter in Ordnung der Weg aus herson war
lebensgefährlich die russischen Besatzer
unkalkulierbar Entführungen
Erschießungen permanent checkt sie die
Lage in der Heimat
als wir hier angekommen sind war es echt
so dass im Vergleich zu all den Gefühlen
die wir auf dem Weg hatten diese Sorgen
als wir dann hier angekommen sind haben
wir einfach nur ruhegefühlt so eine Ruhe
und wie eine Umarmung von Polen echt
angenehm du fühlst ganz viel Mitleid und
ganz viel Hilfe von den Menschen aber
heute Betreuung irina hat eine polnische
Personen Registrierungsnummer bekommen
klingt sehr bürokratisch geht aber für
alle Ukrainerinnen schnell und
unkompliziert die Nummer bedeutet Recht
auf Kindergeld Schule medizinische
Versorgung außerdem gibt es private
Stiftungen wie diese für traumatisierte
Kriegskinder weil jeder etwas verloren
hat Heimathaus manche einen Elternteil
oder Geschwister
es gab Kinder die irgendwelche Bilder
malen ein Messer im Kopf oder jemanden
der getötet wurde
jedes Kind wird das anders erzählen
das ist ein dankesvideo von September
des ukrainischen
Verteidigungsministeriums für Polen für
militärische Unterstützung für die
Solidarität mit den Millionen von
Flüchtlingen die nach Polen flohen
die Ukraine heißt es im Video hätte
nicht um einen großartigeren Freund
bitten können in der Stunde der Notlage
[Musik]
bei den Ukrainern haben die Polen ihr
Herz für Flüchtlinge entdeckt eine
übergangsunterkunft im Grenzort chemisch
viele wollen auch deshalb nach Polen
weil sie zwischendurch immer wieder in
die Ukraine zurückreisen Nachbarschaft
kulturelle Nähe Angst vor Russland
heutzutage das verbindet mehr als 90%
der Flüchtlinge sind Frauen und Kinder
das Mitgefühl für sie ist groß ihr war
geht in eine polnische Schule danach
hilft sie in der Unterkunft
manchmal haben wir mehr Produkte
manchmal weniger das hängt von den
Spenden ab wenn es die nicht gibt ist
das auch ein Problem
im Februar und März waren die Polinnen
und Polen nahezu euphorisch bei der
Hilfe mittlerweile hat das etwas
nachgelassen der Krieg im Nachbarland
man hat sich fast schon daran gewöhnt
bei der Arbeit hier versuchen wir uns
daran zu erinnern dass wir all dies
nicht nur für Flüchtlinge tun sondern
für ganz normale Menschen die wie wir
Träume und Familien haben wir versuchen
alles um Ihnen einen sicheren und
freundlichen Aufenthalt in chemisch zu
ermöglichen
zurück nach jeschuf 90 Kilometer von der
Grenze entfernt 200.000 Einwohnern
normalerweise im Frühling kamen
schlagartig 100.000 dazu aus der Ukraine
die Stadt nahm sie auf ohne große
Debatten natürlich dabei man muss ihnen
helfen im Moment des Krieges wo doch
Kinder getötet werden das ist
schrecklich was da passiert
die finanziellen Belastungen die Plätze
in den Schulen Lehrer für die Kinder das
ist nicht so einfach man braucht
Dolmetscher das ist schon schwierig
südostpolen ist normalerweise nicht
besonders weltoffen trotzdem kippt die
Stimmung nicht
diese gemeinsame Bedrohung und das
Grauen die Brutalität dieses Krieges hat
bei den Polen auch in dieser Region
einen großen Reflex des Herzens
ausgelöst andere Dinge sind da in den
Hintergrund getreten und das ist meiner
Meinung nach der wichtigste Punkt der
uns verbindet die große Bedrohung aus
Russland
außerdem gibt es Arbeit in jeschuf
internationale Firmensitzen hier Irene
aus herson hat einen Masterabschluss in
Bankwesen doch der Daria hat einen
Kindergartenplatz sicher ihre na will
dringend arbeiten auf dem Weg zur
Sprachschule ein hochqualifizierter Job
fällt bis jetzt aus wegen der
Sprachkenntnisse
ich lerne die Sprache so dass ich das
besser verstehen kann um dann in meinem
Fachgebiet zu arbeiten
[Musik]
polnisch und Ukrainisch sind verwandt
das macht es leichter und auch deshalb
bleiben viele in Polen zehn Frauen haben
hier Platz eine ist schon weg weil sie
Arbeit gefunden hat Jeff bietet
kostenlose Kurse an wie viele Städte
oh momento seit Kriegsausbruch seit wir
diese Programme durchführen war die
Belegungsrate sehr hoch die hatten 40
Personen in den Gruppen das Interesse
hat nicht nachgelassen aber es wurden
weitere Programme aufgelegt und auch
Subventionen
Bankerin Irina ist leicht nervös mit dem
Lebenslauf unterwegs zu einer Schule
hier soll es einen Job geben sie hat
keinen Termin versucht es einfach und
trifft auf die vize-direktoren
ich heiße Irina shapovarova ich wollte
fragen ich habe gehört dass die Schule
eine Assistentin für Kinder aus der
Ukraine braucht und schon ja wir suchen
nach einer Person die sowohl hier
übersetzen kann als auch bei den Eltern
manchmal muss man auch den Eltern etwas
erklären
ich habe keine pädagogische Ausbildung
aber ich suche sehr dringend Arbeit ich
möchte Ihnen gerne mein Lebenslauf da
lassen
sie können gleich nächste Woche anfangen
sagt Irina man werde sich bei ihr die
nächsten Tage melden sagt die
vize-direktorin der Bedarf an
ukrainischen Helferinnen an polnischen
Schulen ist riesig
sie wird sich meinen Lebenslauf
anschauen und ich hoffe dass ich dann
endlich die Arbeit bekomme nach der ich
suche ist das ein guter Tag ja ein guter
Tag
ihr war aus der Ostukraine im polnischen
Grenzort chemische präsentiert sich die
polnische freiwilligen Armee die
Soldaten sollen ein Gefühl von
Sicherheit geben für Jever schlimm genug
dass das nötig ist
mit 15 nur mit Mutter und kleinem Bruder
gekommen der Vater blieb in der Ukraine
wie fast alle Männer viele kämpfen
unterwegs auf einen Hügel an der Grenze
von polnischer Seite blickt Jever von
hier aus Richtung Heimat
900 Kilometer ist der Vater von ihr
entfernt
wir werden weiterhin in Polen bleiben
weil es in der Ukraine nicht sicher ist
im Haus einer Freundin 400 Meter von uns
zu Hause entfernt wurden zwei
Obergeschosse zerstört
niemand weiß ob er morgen noch am Leben
ist
im Moment ist es eher ruhig an der
Grenze aber spätestens wenn die Kälte
zuschlägt Energie in der Ukraine knapp
wird rechnen sich hier mit einer neuen
Flüchtlingswelle und dann steht Polen
das selbst mit hohen Preisen kämpft vor
der nächsten Herausforderung um sein
freundliches Gesicht zu bewahren
nach Polen kommen ukrainische
geflüchtete mein Kollege Sebastian ehm
war in georg in unterwegs und hat dort
mit Menschen gesprochen die aus Russland
geflohen sind
unsere ganze Dokumentation über die
weltweiten Folgen des Ukraine Kriegs
kann man in der Mediathek finden unter
diesem Link und unseren Kanal für noch
mehr News und Hintergrundinfos kann man
gerne abonnieren